[Music]
okay everybody welcome to office hours
is where I interact with founders some
of which I've already invested in some
of which I might investment in and some
of which I would never invest in and the
goal of office hours is for me to just
carve out a little bit of my time and
give founders the best advice the most
candid honest advice if this is too
candid for you stop watching now because
it's only to get more candid next up is
a founder who emailed me and I found his
business fascinating his name is Eli and
his business is called learn to fly air
and there at Elte FAI are calm so LT
fair Calm learn to fly air I know what
you do you basically have four seed
planes that you might learn in I guess I
guess s know what they call it 172
weren't some before Cirrus sr22 oh
they're serious with that with the
parachute that's right I love that plane
that is the CEO plane that is the plane
that CEOs buy and then wind up flying
into weather and pulling the parachute
on and destroying a $500,000 plane we
want to train them not to do that got it
but there are actually pretty amazing
planes and your concept here is they can
take flight lessons while they're going
to a meeting that's right oh it's super
efficient and it's a bit of a hack isn't
it what's the hack in this business it's
an interesting description hack I think
it's apropos you know find instructors
have been going on trips with their
students forever it's a logical great
place to learn the lessons you need to
be a good safe pilot the hack part is
you know we're working with the FAA the
FAA is a great organization all about
safety all about consumer advocacy and
so they're interested in making sure
that operators so what consumers
understand they're getting and so what
we're not providing is a charter service
so we have to work within the existing
regulatory body and advertise and
provide a real safe low stress
educational flight lesson to
legitimately operate and therein lies
you know
the hack we have to provide real
education while you're going
from A to B and why not just provide a
charter service great question charters
operate under a different area of F a
regulatory code that is far more
comprehensive and far more expensive
which makes it from a price perspective
unaffordable to a mass public which I
found interesting when I did my
discovery flight at Santa Monica Airport
in one of those Cessna they called 172
or 174 is 172 probably have 172 those
planes that have the short wingspan and
gets kind of thrown around in the air
after just bumpy it feels a little bumpy
I think it was $100 or $150 yeah that's
a classic intro flight you didn't go
anywhere you just went up yeah for an
hour and Illume landed back at Santa
Monica yeah there's not a lot of utility
in a classic flight lesson you learn but
you don't go anywhere
got it so I go to Santa Monica and Los
Angeles on a regular basis so take me
through what it would cost me to fly
there do a day's worth of meetings and
fly back and learn twelve to thirteen
hundred dollars and there's 1,200 to
1,300 dollars 680 a depends on which
airport you land net and there's room
for three students in the classroom got
it
so for 600 bucks I could do door-to-door
essentially yep or 700 bucks each way
and I typically spend whatever three or
400 each way so I'm sorry five hundred
dollars each way so it's probably saves
it's probably $200 more expensive to
leave when I want get where I want and
learn yes that is if I was comparing it
to Southwest it's just you in the
airplane yes yeah yeah I would think it
would be just me and I think for most
people so and then for the instructor
you can take me through the economics of
the instructor well the key here in the
business from a profitability and
providing real wages to instructors is
network efficiency so we need to
schedule out and have customers in a
variety of locations so that we can
optimize now do I get the market thing
I'm talking about
take me through one flight if I had had
that same instructor hmm just fly me
around for an hour and a half
twice which are you you know two lessons
yeah what would they have gotten paid
versus flying me down there for the day
and flying me back and what would they
have
gotten paid well we're looking at
compensation in the neighborhood of 60
$80 an hour for the instructor so for
the there and back there at a day rate
and that's not gonna occupy their whole
day of somewhere between 250 and 300
dollars and what is it how does that
compare to what they would get just
teaching lessons or is it that they
would just get more lessons to teach if
they can do it consistently it's easily
double the trip of what they're making
now great what's your biggest challenge
with the business because that's why
we're here for office hours now that
we've explained it the biggest challenge
with the business is the regulatory hack
element so when we talk to investors
they like the consumer experience they
like the pricing they they see the value
and they understand the operations that
we've done to date when we talk about
the FAA the question is are you approved
and so we have strategies on both sides
of the risk versus reward equation where
we're trying to execute but my
co-founder and I haven't previously done
a regulatory hack so how do we connect
and work with angels or do we need a
different founder that's got regulatory
hack experience do we need a particular
brand of angels or do we need to educate
them how it works yeah so this is very
similar to Airbnb or maybe uber in that
they had a new model that maybe people
had not seen before
same thing with crypto doing icos and so
which have to look at in this case when
I look at things that are either bending
regulations or reinterpreting them or
just innovating on them right so I look
at yours and I see a virtuous innovation
I would actually learn to like to learn
I would love to learn to fly and I would
love to have a private jet you know our
private cirrus to take me to Santa
Monica next on Wednesday when I go that
would be actually a cool experience for
me and if it was 1,200 bucks I might
actually consider it because it's pretty
much inconsequential to me if I pay 800
or 1,200 right and I think probably most
of these high-end consumers are going
after would love this experience and I
don't think it's disingenuous so
don't think people are gonna do it and
then fall asleep and not and want to sit
in the backseat and not take a lesson I
think if they're gonna be in the plane
getting a lesson it's kind of fun right
sitting up front it's a peak experience
it doesn't think it's wrong it's
engaging so I don't see it like crypto
where you're like I'm doing a utility
token and you're gonna pay me for my
utility token and utility tokens are not
securities even though I'm buying them
from Pete I'm selling them to people I
don't know and doing FOMO marketing
right so a lot of times when I look at
this I try to interpret are you on the
good side or the bad side and what I
mean by that is are you out for yourself
with this innovation or are you out to
make the world better and a better
consumer experience yours is clearly in
the latter you're making a better
consumer experience why not combine a
trip I have to take with learning it's
just efficient it's brilliant no person
FAA charter company nobody would look at
that and go oh they're just trying to
screw people over in this case nobody's
being screwed everybody's a winner right
if you look at the icos it was very
clear that they were going to screw the
people who were sending the money and
that they were breaking the regulations
in a major way you're not breaking any
regulations
I know people who take lessons and who
the point of them having a charter is
for them to get ours and they're using
going to Tahoe as a part of their
training right to land in a new airport
so I think you're so far on the good
side that I think most angels will get
it and I would not present it as a hack
I'd presented as an innovation okay and
I would work very hard with the FAA to
inform them of what you're doing and to
make friends with them and if you look
at what navall did with angel list
mm-hmm and I think the folks at funders
club and seedinvest also were part of
this they went to the SEC and they said
here's what we're doing hey we're just
informing you of what we're doing we
want to be upfront with you we're going
to you saying hey here's why this is a
good idea and then some of the scooter
companies did that some of the scooter
companies didn't do it
I like the companies doing that because
it just reduces risk and in today's day
and age where technology companies have
had a little bit of a bad reputation of
being a little
too aggressive in innovating I like the
idea of in 2019 and going forward to
informing them asking them for feedback
letting them know and really crossing
your T's and dotting your I I don't I
think having a good law firm is a good
start who you know handles education and
then maybe being affiliated with
instructors who have a great reputation
so this is a super hack if your
instructors worked at the FAA before
right they worked at the regulatory
organs and now they're training when the
FAA comes and says hey can I Oh Jose
there Oh Susan's there great so this is
a hack it turns out that a lot of the
people who do defense work previously
worked at the attorney general's office
Wow when they're defending some
high-priced white-collar criminal they
worked at the AG's office in the
Southern District of New York and then
they went on to the other side of the
table just like hey I was a founder and
now I'm an investor you know I've been
on both sides of the table get up both
sides at a table person on the team you
know as an advisor maybe so a former FAA
person is now an advisor they have a
half-point of equity make sense yep
that's a couple elements that we're
currently executing to a film that'll be
enough fall squarely and you just
described the instructor one is an area
we can focus more on yeah at this point
you don't need to make a profit off of
each one of these if you overpaid to get
some killer instructors and you pitch
this as an elite product high-end
product then I think it's gonna make it
even safer you're saying we're not
trying to take Southwest passengers
we're going after CEOs venture
capitalists high net worth individuals
who genuinely can afford to buy this
plane who genuinely want a career has a
charter person they've expressed this
interest mm-hmm so when you get people
to sign up you could ask them is your
primary interest commuting or learning
or both right if they say the primary
interest is in commuting then you don't
let them book we have a charter for
service we can you redirect them to that
if you do just that then you have this
massive cover you say to the FAA look on
the form you have three choices hey I'm
looking
charter service B I'm looking to learn C
I'm looking for a charter service that
allows me to learn at the same time B
and C we think are fantastic a we
redirect them into a charter and we tell
them they sit in the back seat they can
sleep and they don't have to do this
yeah we we've conceptualized we'll have
customers that will have to fire yeah
because they won't want to learn
absolutely and then what you do is you
have the instructors rate the student
how much do they pay attention in the
you tell the FAA look if they say they
paid full attention partial attention
you know we're not we're not attentive
we if they pay full attention we do them
again if they paid half attention we let
them know they need to pay full
attention on the next one and if they
didn't pay attention we tell them that
this isn't the right service of them and
we redirect them in the future
correct yeah perfect you're good love
your business I'm excited about your
business I want to know when you get to
10 or 20 of these a week where are you
right now
six seven perfect like I said when you
get to ten to twenty a week then it
becomes real let's keep talking it might
be something that where you'd fit into
the accelerator excellent all right
we'll be right back
[Music]